hi guys I'm Eric Voss and this is a
breakdown of The Walking Dead Season
eight episode 11 a dead or alive or
title taken from Megan's final line this
episode Dead or Alive
or some kind of in-between which I guess
applies to Gabriel who's now living in
an existence where he sees everything
through a booty hole definitely some in
between there I'm gonna run through this
episode one out all the parallels and
connections you might have missed and
what this all means for these characters
going forward let's start with a big
question something tweet and commented
by a lot of you guys why does negan
think his Walker guts plan will work
this episode ended with negan explaining
to the Savior's his new strategy cover
their weapons with infected Walker blood
and guts so that they only have to wound
Rick's people and then let the infection
take over now the confusion with that is
on this show we've seen characters
wounded in ways that would almost
certainly get them infected with Walker
blood and survived no problem Rick
impaled his hand on one of Winslow's
spikes in the landfill last season
though I don't know if his what actually
made contact with the walkers flesh or
fluids the fluids weird back in season
two Shane cut his hand with a knife that
he had just been using to kill walkers
and in season bored Daryl casually held
a bolt in his mouth after plugging it in
and Walker said really guys if you'd go
back and re-watch this entire show no
one is really being that sanitary when
it comes to their open the wounds around
walkers this isn't World War Z for 28
days later no one's using Purell here
and Rick learned from the CDC that
everyone whether or not they get bitten
is infected with the virus and that it
will turn them whenever they die anyway
a bite just speeds up that process so
again why does negan see this is such a
big game-changer now I would say negan
could just be less informed about the
virus he wasn't at the CDC after all
that was really privileged insider
information that Rick got but when Sasha
killed herself in that casket and then
jumped out at negan he was really more
curious over how she killed herself than
by the fact that she turned despite not
getting bitten seems like he just kind
of figured that out from experience
really negan I think just sees this as a
new form of war
they're inspired by Eugene's proposal to
catapult Walker parts over the walls
something I think we all need to see at
some point cuz it's awesome
Meghan just wants to try a form of
chemical warfare in psychological
warfare rather than killing your enemy
outright you make them sick and cause a
panic that destabilizes them from the
inside out that's the idea behind the
various real-world nerve gases that were
developed in the 20th century and why
many of them were classified as inhumane
in the Geneva Accords Meghan believes
that merging their current danger
manpower and firepower with that of the
walkers German power is the key to
bringing Rick to heel and without
spoiling anything coming up yeah this
plan by negan is taken directly from the
comics this she won 22 so this is
actually important to the narrative guys
it's not just our random thing added to
the show but ultimately I think getting
that scientific confirmation from dr.
Jenner and the CDC early on instilled
Rick and his crew with a sort of
reckless dirty bravery that might
explain why they survive this long but
more on that later for now let's move on
to some of the other ways this episode
reminded us of past episodes in our
segment callbacks and speaking of
negan's Walker gut plan this final
close-up of Lucille covered in Walker
blood as he tells us man
look that parallels the moment in his
infamous line up with Rick's crew when
he said look at this look at my dirty
girl for negan it's like he's returning
to that feeling of pride when he could
actually still shock and scare it into
submission
another connection I saw was the radio
broadcaster Gabriel and Harlan stumbled
upon Harlan reads this script that the
guy had for anyone who can hear my voice
know that you're not alone please hold
on we can make it through this if we
don't give up if we keep leaving etc etc
remember earlier in the series Rick used
to broadcast similar messages over
emergency channels in the radio hoping
to connect with any other survivors out
there even though Harlan dismisses it
Gabriel interprets repeatedly sending a
positive message out into the airwaves
and not expecting a response as an
analogy for prayer and he's embracing
that optimism that season one Rick still
had the reality
that this Brady Oh broadcaster killed
himself and the fact that this storyline
really ended with Gabriel back in
custody with Harlan dead is a really
grim reminder of the Bleak place this
show has come to it also makes you
wonder why we even watched this multiple
episodes subplot I guess the writers
want us to think with Sadiq now on the
show two doctors is just too many for
the zombie apocalypse and Gabriel's
foolish for believing in the higher
power now that said I am very interested
in Gabriel's booty hole blindness and I
have some more thoughts on that later
another parallel was Henreid a creepy
Kingdom kid staring down the savior pows
at the hilltop after he killed Gavin we
talked about how that episode painted
Henry has a parallel figure to Carl back
in season 3 when he shot that Woodbury
kid Carl ended up taking the high road
in his life but the fear now is that
Henry is taking the dark path this
debate between Morgan and Carol is
overseen by Maggie who later learns that
Carl died by helping a stranger
her decision to show benevolence and
mercy to the prisoners echoes the way
her father Hershel reacted to Carl back
in that moment he saw that young
reckless inhumanity as a warning sign
for all of their souls and his daughter
Maggie is both inspired by Carl's mercy
and concerned with Henry's wrath moving
her to now share the rations with the
prisoners and if we're looking at past
episodes guys we've got to talk about
Tara this episode and I'm sorry Tara
sucks her ongoing stubbornness and
refusal to accept Dwight switching sides
in this war just completely hypocritical
considering yeah she did the same
freakin thing she fought for the
governor she stood right next to him
when he chopped off Maggie's dad's head
now sure she didn't fire on Rick or kill
anyone the way Dwight did but
considering how grateful she was when
Rick and Maggie let her stay with them
Tara should have some sympathy for a
convert also can we just say it's a
little weird to see Tara mourn Denise
for this long considering they were only
together for like one or two episodes I
think we saw them one scene
of them even talking from what I
remember look I know we were all sad
when Denis died Tara but it's time to
move on Rick's son just died two
episodes ago and Rick is already asking
who's coral anyway Thank You Daryl for
yelling in Tara's face here maybe throw
a walker at her while you're at it okay
let's move on to a few cultural
influences that showed up this episode
and our segment under the influence and
first Gabriel in Harlan's storyline
notice what car they're driving it's a
green Jaguar it's a little odd that in
this zombie apocalypse these fugitives
are driving such a luxury car with a
pretty good shine no less but maybe it's
just because it's a reference another
famous zombies story Shaun of the Dead
Simon Pegg and Nick Frost ik bill Nikes
green Jaguar yeah I guess we'll have to
take the Jag the walking dead crew has
been known to make similar little nods
to pass zombie movies so that wouldn't
surprise me if this is an intentional
easter egg there's also this piggy bank
with the I heart ham radio on the side
you gotta love that pun it ends up
containing keys and a map exactly what
Gabriel and Harlan needed for their
salvation
Gabriel points us out as an example of
his faith leading to spiritual salvation
or salvation from within this may be a
stretch but I see a parallel between
these fugitives and the Shawshank
Redemption Andy Dufresne who becomes a
fugitive hid his tool of salvation in
plain sight inside his Bible writing
salvation lies within as a lesson for
the warden both Shawshank and The
Walking Dead series were directed by
Frank Darabont so they're really
spiritual ancestors at least I also
think there may be some deeper meaning
to Gabriel's blindness his illness
causing him to lose his vision maybe
transforming Gabriel into the blind seer
archetype of literature and mythology
the blind seer is a character who's
literally blind but possesses some
divine powers that give them deeper
insight or predictive abilities often
these figures are men of faith like
Gabriel is in Greek mythology and
theatrical traditions there was the
character Therese the
lines soothsayer who possessed cryptic
knowledge of the future they're also
various pop culture blind seers like
daredevil and the Marvel Comics and his
also blind since a stick and yeah
Gabriel must have been using some kind
of super echolocation to be able to
shoot that Walker no one should ever
operate a firearm while looking through
a booty hole anyway I predict Gabriel's
blindness will result in something
greater than just a disability but let's
talk about the deeper meaning of this
episode remember its title is alive or
dead or some kind of in between from
negan's final line now I mentioned
before that ever since the CDC in season
one Rick and his people have made every
move with the knowledge that they're
already infected
however they die they're gonna turn the
walkers no matter what and I think that
sort of death sentence has given them an
edge in these years sense if you can
lose each other at any moment why not
risk it all at every opportunity that
willingness to go all-in is what
separates them from the other groups of
survivors that they encounter so if
negan thinks he can scare Rick Maggie
and the rest with this idea of being
neither dead nor alive but some kind of
between he's definitely wrong they've
already felt like some kind of between
for the entire time that we've known
them and that hasn't scared them one bit
and let's move on to this week's kill
count after last week's record
shattering number of human casualties we
only saw one person die this episode dr.
Carson because the medical profession of
the Walking Dead is apparently the
equivalent of Defense Against the Dark
Arts professor when it comes to turnover
so we'll measure the kill count this
weekend Walker takedowns which makes
Daryl the deadliest by my count he
killed at least four walkers probably
more as they cleared that swamp but a
question for you guys
considering next week's previews make it
seem like Simon is laying the seeds for
some kind of mutiny do you think Simon
would be a more effective leader of the
Savior's than negan comment down below
and let me know your thoughts or tweet
me directly at ei vas and follow new
rockstars on Twitter for updates on our
videos and you can like this video and
subscribe to new rock stars for all of
our deep obsessive psychotic analysis
The Walking Dead and yeah make sure to
check out on my breakdowns of the past
episodes this season for all the other
stuff that you might have missed thanks
for watching guys bye